okay let's get started
I hope uh you all enjoyed lunch
and are well rested for this afternoon
session with uh Darren mangrove
so this session will be about U.S census
data in Python
but before we start I'm going to
introduce you to
um Darren
and
um so Darren is a senior vice president
for uh to Sigma he works in New York so
he flew in
um for the weekend or last Friday and
have some time to spend here in Seattle
so he's not fully champlacked
um yeah and um he has PhD in computer
science from uh Brown University and
well it is a volunteering data scientist
for Community Coalition on Race So if
you have questions regarding that or you
have questions regarding the workshop
today feel free to to uh you know check
in with him afterwards and ask those
questions but I'll we'll pass it on now
today
[Music]
all right thank you everyone hear me
yeah okay thank you for the introduction
and thanks everyone for coming uh this
being a tutorial format uh as you can
see I don't have slides I'll actually be
presenting from uh a notebook or a
couple of different notebooks
um if you haven't had a chance yet or
hopefully some of you had to go to the
GitHub repo where
these notebooks are housed and there's a
link there where you can actually run
them live from a container at
mybinder.org if you'd like to follow
along that way
um
no promises there you know if there's
some network issues or sometimes
mybinders a little on the slow side I
won't have time to stop and debug those
you'll have to just just follow along on
the main screen but uh you know if you
do if it does work for you and you're uh
you want to change a few things here and
there you know please please do so
all right so uh just a little background
in history on what I'm going to be
talking about today so the origin story
of the package I'm going to be talking
about it's probably a little different
than uh than some of the others you'll
you'll hear about uh today in the next
couple days so it started out at the
Community Coalition on a Race So This is
a 25 year old organization in New Jersey
that is dedicated to
encouraging stable diversity and
integration in the communities that
serves so you know diversity and
integration are not the same thing you
can have a diverse town but you know if
all the black people live on this side
and all the white people live on that
side it's not integrated so they've been
doing this like I said for 25 years
census data is a big part of what they
use and when they started the way you've
got Census Data was you literally
mail-ordered it right you wrote a check
you sent it to the Census Bureau and
do a CD-ROM that had the data you wanted
on it on so been doing that for years
2020 it's about time to to maybe try
something a little more modern that's
when I got involved and we started
um you know using the census API through
an existing python package that was
called
census data and then we built our own
package on top of that called div in seg
for diversity integration and
segregation that could analyze this data
and compute some of those metrics and
give you an entire another talk about
the various methodologies there it's
super interesting stuff
and that worked really well until 2022
when uh support for Census Data ended
right so now we have this interface we
liked that would be written on top of it
we had the diversity integration
segregation code that we really liked on
on top of that and the bottom had kind
of fallen out from so we just did the
bullet and said all right let's just
write the new bottom layer of that stack
and that's where census disk came from
so the the open source pack or the
package we've now open sourced uh which
I'm gonna talk about today so I've also
used that elsewhere so a two Sigma my my
day job when I'm not volunteering at CCR
we have a group called the data Clinic
that does uh pro bono data science work
for a variety of non-profits in
different fields we recently did a
project with housing Navigator of
Massachusetts this is a non-profit on
what they do is they get they've
gathered a really solid proprietary data
set on availability of affordable
housing within their state and then what
we did is we helped them build kind of a
census data side of that bring them
together and and generate some some
interesting new insight
um there's actually a blog post that
didn't quite get published in time but
uh I'll I'll post a link for it uh
shortly after this should be out next
week and then more recently I used the
same code to build an interactive map of
the entire United States you can find it
at the URL there and you can zoom in and
out and see exactly where the diverse
and or integrated areas are in the
United States at you know at all
different levels and all the data uh
all the data retrieval from the Census
and Analysis was all done with this
package and then fast forward to now
here we are at Pi data Seattle uh thanks
everyone for for coming to hear about
this so just a quick outline of kind of
the the remainder of our 90 minutes so
uh in the first half I'm going to jump
right in and this is a intended to be
Hands-On so I'm going to go straight to
a hello world where you will get some
some data and then we'll really build up
from there and look at getting different
variables different geographies
um understanding how we can plot those
on a map and manipulate them and uh and
then towards the end of the first half
of the presentation I'll kind of uh go
back to the beginning and say well how
did we know these variables this is
sometimes the hardest problem with
Census Data you've got you know over a
thousand different data sets some of
them have tens of thousands of variables
so how do we actually discover you know
the variables that we used in the
example that I'm going to so I'll talk
about that that'll get us a little over
halfway through the 90 minutes I'll give
everyone a five minute break to kind of
stand up and stretch your legs a bit
and then in the second half we'll go
kind of from front to back you know
starting with the metadata and discovery
on a project where we'll start you know
just with a basic research question like
where are their children living in
poverty in Newark New Jersey and we'll
go all the way from where do we find the
variables on that how do we download
them how do we generate a map that that
actually shows these things in a way
that we might present to a client or
agency
and then finally there will be time at
the end for discussion q a there's
actually a third notebook that's a
little bit more of a Mad Lib that can
get you started on your own research
question where you can fill in sort of
what you're looking for and follow
basically the recipe that I did in the
new urgency
all right with that so let's jump right
into our first hello world query so for
every query we're never going to make uh
from the Census API we're going to need
to know four things so we're going to
need to specify four things one is
What's called the data set so the census
publishes lots of different data sets
some of them have many variables some of
them have a few some of them cover only
certain ranges of time some of them have
been going on for a long time we'll use
one initially called the American
Community survey or ACS is probably the
most widely used census data set it's
very wide it covers a lot of years it's
it's a quite a detailed survey I was
actually thrilled recently I got in the
mail a flyer from from the Census Bureau
I was actually selected to participate
in the survey this year which has never
happened so I guess you know some years
down the road something I wrote in that
survey might appear in this data set but
the next thing is the Vintage so we'll
use the Vintage 2020 so vintage is just
when the data is from and obviously you
know all the variables change over time
so we have to specify what point in time
we're looking for
the third thing is what variable do we
actually want in this example I'll look
for median household income I'll just
just just one variable and then the
geography right so these data sets cover
a lot of different geographies in this
case since we're in Seattle I'll ask for
Washington State right so my query is
according to the ACs data set
um
in the year 2020 what was the median
household income now you'll see the
variable here for median household
income is
b19013 underscore 001e so I'm sure you
know you're all very familiar with that
but
in in reality you know every every
variable that they publish has some
funky alphanumeric name like that and
like I said we'll we'll get to uh how we
discovered that that was median
household income but for now just just
take my word for it and then the
geography
um I'm going to call this API with state
with this constant which is the state of
Washington right and so I run that and
what I get back is this data frame it's
an ordinary pandas data frame I can do
whatever I would do with data frames and
uh you know what does it actually
contain right so it contains one row for
each geography
we only asked for the state of
Washington so we only get one row and it
has two columns uh the First Column is
State
um it doesn't really tell us much here
because we only asked for one state and
the value there five three that's
something called the fips code that's a
code that the census uses to represent
States and counties so 53 is the fips
code for the state of Washington and
then finally the last value 77 0006
that's the data we actually wanted the
median household income in the state of
Washington in 2020 was seventy seven
thousand and six dollars
okay so pretty simple query let's extend
it a little bit and what I'll do as I go
through these examples is I'll leave
typically a bunch of the arguments the
same and then I'll I'll put a comment on
whatever I've Chained and so here in
this case what I'm saying is Well I
don't care just about Washington I'd
like all three states on the west coast
right so instead I passed a list of the
constants for Washington Oregon and
California not surprisingly I got back
three rows in the data frame one for
each state and of course you know post
six is California which if you look at
Census Data all the time you would know
and probably none of you know or
recognize uh 5'3 is Washington and which
has not quite as high in median
household income as California and then
41 is Washington is sorry Oregon which
is lower so
those aren't super friendly so there's
something I add pretty much to every
query I ever do which is this other
variable whose name is just name right
so I say you know median household
income and whatever else I want to query
but also give me this variable name and
that name is just the name of the
geography right so now I get that column
back I have something you know probably
a lot more useful certainly if I'm then
going to put that on a chart and want to
use those as labels or something right
so I just added that name to the list of
variables that I want
so next thing I can do is I can say well
you know
I might not want just those three states
I might want all of them and I can type
out all 50 constants but but I don't
want to do that so instead I can just
pass a wild card right I can say State
equals star and now that's going to get
me a data frame that again has all the
states in it uh actually if you notice
the data frame has 52 rows not 50 as I
would expect and the reason is because
it also includes Washington DC and
Puerto Rico so these aren't States but
the Census Bureau considers them to be
state-like enough that typically when
you query for State data in most data
sets you'll get DC and Puerto Rico data
as well
so this is a completely ordinary pandas
data frame I got back right
um so we can do completely ordinary
pandas data frame type of things with
right so for example if I want to say
well what are the 10 states with the
largest median income I just you know
use the method and largest on that data
frame that I just downloaded from the
Census give it the variable I want and
here are the top 10 in the descending
order you'll notice actually number one
is uh is Washington DC a non-state right
or
um and then you know Maryland New Jersey
Etc uh down the line or if I wanted to
get the the bottom 10 same thing but
it's and smallest method on the data
frame and in this case actually you know
it turns out both ends of the spectrum
are are the two uh or the district and
the territory that aren't States
um
in terms of median income but but again
they're they're grouped in
okay great so a lot of times when I'm
dealing with uh with
data that has to do with States or
counties or whatever other geography I'd
like to visualize that on a map right
I'd like to be able to to present that
to you know whatever my final audiences
in terms of the map and in order to do
that I have to be able to somehow get
you know what is the geometry of each
state or County or whatever and I can do
that very simply just by adding this one
argument with this one optional argument
with geometry is true right and if I set
that to true what happens well instead
of getting back an ordinary data frame I
get something called a geodata frame
which some of you may be familiar with
it looks and smells pretty much exactly
like an ordinary data frame except it
has this extra comp special column
called geometry right and if I look at
geometry uh for every state in in the
data frame I have either a polygon like
in the case of Pennsylvania that has all
the lat Longs of line segments that draw
the outline of the state right or in the
case of California it's a multi-polygon
because California has the big Mainland
piece and then a few you know Catalina
and a few other islands are are their
own polygons typically you know Coastal
States I'll I'll see a multi-polygon
interior States usually are aren't just
a single poly note but now that I have
those polygons and I also have the
median household to become in each of
those States I can plot those results on
a map very easily and we created this
convenience method uh plot us that makes
it easy to do that I could just plot the
geodata frame itself the reason we have
this API is because it produces Maps
like this you'll notice that it does
things like it relocates Alaska and
Hawaii down here you know where Mexico
would normally be to save space and not
leave a bunch of empty Pacific Ocean in
between it relocates Puerto Rico as well
it also uses a map projection where you
know you can see the 49th parallel here
on the Canadian border is is curved as
as it often is and it just kind of looks
a little nicer for presentation than
just a straight line across it's a it's
a view that you know most of us are
accustomed to seeing and then every
state is filled in with a color based on
its median uh household income right so
I just said use this variable this data
frame full of states and then I added a
couple of keyword Arts like add a legend
and you know how big I wanted the figure
to be uh it uses matplotlib under the
covers and so you can add any keyword
args you want that Matt plotlet would
understand and pass them through uh
and affect the plot and so actually if
we if we do that in this example you
know I just added a few more I chose a
different color map change some colors
and line widths and then I set the Min
and Max values of the of the household
income so you know this picture is you
know depending on your view maybe a
little more pleasing than the
than the earlier ones right and I can
see exactly which states have you know
relatively higher or lower medium ounces
all right so we've been talking about
State something out right we loaded uh
this data just at the state level uh
Census Data comes in all different kinds
of geographies not just state right
um so now look I'm going to look at a
few of those different geographies so
I'm going to make the same query
although actually I'm only going to
query for a name because I'm more
interested in just showing what what
some of these geographies look like at
this point
and I ask for all the states and I plot
them and you know sure enough I get a
very familiar
map of the United States but if I wanted
to zoom in a little bit let's say I
don't want to know just say the
household median household income for
Washington State I want to know it on a
county by county basis within Washington
state right so what I can do is I can
specify my geometry not by just saying
State equals Washington or state equals
star to get all the states but saying
state is Washington and county is star
so this is saying get the data Forever
at the county level for every County in
Washington state right and if I plot
those you know here's here's Washington
State uh here's King County where we are
right now and the various other counties
and I can keep zooming in with this same
basic approach right I I can zoom into
King County so first I need to know what
Phipps code of King County is so I can
query for it and so again this is an
ordinary data frame so I just look for
what row in that data frame has a name
that starts with King right and there's
only one its name is King County
Washington and there we go I know it's
it's code is 33. so what I'll do then is
I'll zoom into that County by specifying
not star but that specific County and
then I'm going to ask for something
called a census tract so every county is
divided up into what the Census Bureau
calls census tracts these are areas
where typically between one and five
thousand people live right so if I do
that again I I just say state of
Washington I say the specific County I
want and then I say all all tracks so
all census tracts and it looks like this
right so over here on the western side
side of the county you know downtown
Seattle Capitol Hill and so on these
census tracts are very dense right the
population is dense in those urban areas
whereas if I go out to the Eastern side
of the county
um the census tracts are much bigger
geographically so uh the reason for that
of course is they all have somewhere in
the sort of one to five thousand people
range and so whenever you look at a map
like this you can always tell where the
urban areas are because the census
tracks are much smaller where the the
rural areas are where they're they're
much larger
okay the next level and and the finest
level of uh that's available in the ACs
data the American Community survey data
that we've been looking at something
called the block group some of the data
sets actually go down to individual city
blocks and we'll see that later but the
ACs goes down to the block group which
is kind of a collection of blocks
somewhere between 500 and a thousand
people uh somewhere in that range and
same thing if we plot them on the map
right they're super super dense in the
urban areas a little less dense in the
suburbs over here on on this side of
Lake Washington and then in the rural
areas they're still massive they just
just aren't a lot of people living over
there right so we've looked at the
geographies of kind of what they look
like but we really want to get census
data right we want to do things like
like our query for median household
income so we can do that here all I did
is I added back in the median household
income variable so I have name and
median household income same thing I
want all the block groups in all the
tracks in King County and then this
final additional argument I added there
are some cases where the census API will
return special values and they typically
look like minus six six six six like
nine sixes minus seven sections and so
on they're numeric but they're basically
specifying different reasons why there's
no data for that particular geography
sometimes it's like you know it's an
industrial area no one actually lives
there
um other times it's too few two people
live there and for privacy reasons they
don't want to expose certain variables
there are a number of reasons but what
I'm going to do here is I'm going to say
okay for now I'm not I don't care so
much about the reason I just want to say
if you see any of those special
variables set it to another number in
the pandas data frame and then I'm you
know
in my work in the various tools I use
we're used to seeing a lot of numbers
and dealing with them so we'll do that
and then what we'll do is we will plot
uh kind of a background color of purple
and then plot at the block group level
our median household income right so now
we have the whole County right super
dense uh over here the highest median
household income is sort of a Long Lake
Washington here and then a little
further out uh in kind of the excerbs
um you know some of the southern part of
of the county
um quite a bit lower median household
income and somewhere in the middle in
the rural
so you know in just one quick query and
and uh call to the plot API I've got a
map of King County with a lot of
potentially useful information on it in
terms of what the median household
income is
all right so
we dug down from state to County to
census tract to block group that's what
the census tract or refers to as on or
what the Census Bureau refers to as an
on-spine geometry what that means is
every level of the hierarchy completely
tiles and fills the level outside right
so there's no place in a state that's
not an accountant there's no place in a
county that's not in a census tract but
they also publish tons of different
what's called off-spine geographies
right so these are geographies that
don't necessarily fill the whole plane
but are useful and interesting in a
variety of ways right and so we're going
to make our our sort of first step into
metadata by by trying to ask well what
of what are some of these other
geographies that are available right and
this is a little visualization of kind
of what they look like the on spine is
in the middle and then there are these
various other things places Urban growth
areas urban areas that each has their
own kind of definition of what they are
they're actually more than they're even
shown in this picture and we'll see that
now by query we can just say okay what
geographies are available for the data
set right we say what's available for
the ACs 5 that we've been using in the
Vintage 2020. how do we get all these
results right and every single one of
these uh little lists is a set of valid
parameters uh keyword args that we can
pass when we want to download data right
so before you know already we use the
state we used State and County we used
State and County and tracked we didn't
do accounting self-deviction but
um there are you know basically using a
combination of constants and wild cards
I can query you know data at any of
these different levels some of them
nested inside States some of them don't
some of them are very sparse and you can
see there's a there's a whole lot of
right so I'm going to start with one uh
you know one of the early rows in there
specified State and place so a place in
census terminology is what typically an
incorporated area right so it's a city
or a town or you know in some states
like New Jersey there are townships and
Villages which are slightly different
but it they they all are are called uh
places right and they're off spine so
they don't necessarily fill up the whole
state there are there are adapts in
between right so if I query for median
household income and I say state of
Washington all places then what I get
back is a data frame you know that has
all the places and I have all their
names right the first one is is Aberdeen
right so any Nirvana fans in the
audience that's you know where they got
their start
um and you know plenty of other
different
um
places in Washington and so now if I
plot those you know what I can do is
first thing I'm going to do is is get
the outline of all of Washington so I
can plot that in like a beige background
color and then I say okay on top of that
I want to plot the median household
income of all these places right and and
you know sort of style and format that a
little bit and so now I have this right
you can see there are a lot of places
over here in western Washington cities
towns suburbs and so on out in Eastern
Washington there are a lot more sparse
it doesn't mean no one lives in these
gaps in between but it means there
aren't you know sort of formal
Incorporated places there
and depending on how I want to present
this data instead of drawing the
background map of Washington state
myself what I could do is add this with
background equals true argument I wasn't
using that before because it wasn't
really relevant I was on spine and I
would have covered everything up anyway
but if I do specify that then download
some tiles from open street maps uses
those as the background and produces you
know a map where you can see the roads
and sort of you know where the different
towns are along these roads and rivers
and so on
all right so let's look at one more kind
of geography so places where within
States there's another commonly used
kind of geography that some people call
a cbsa or core based statistical area
it's made up of either what's called a
micro Pawn area which is a aerial
population of between 10 and 50 000 or a
metropolitan area which is an area with
50 000 or more people
um but you'll notice in the query we did
above the metadata query it doesn't Nest
inside state so uh cbsas can cross state
boundaries right they're not bound by uh
that nesting and in fact they they very
often do right so here I'll query you
know the median household income and
then this other variable
bo3002 underscore 001e which is total
population so I'm going to get the name
median household income and total
population of every cbsa in the country
and then because uh I don't want to plot
them all I just want to plot the 100
largest I'll say okay let me take the
100 largest you know filtered out of
that data frame I got back
um plot those on a map of the US and
here's what I get right so now I've seen
the the 100 largest metropolitan areas
here's Seattle well here's the Portland
metro area which which actually crosses
the border into Washington State some of
the suburbs like like Vancouver
um you know places like in Missouri both
Kansas City and St Louis metro areas
across state lines and going to other
states right and I can also very quickly
look at this and say oh the one with the
highest median income is the DC uh cbsa
which includes parts of Maryland and
Virginia right and uh you know San
Francisco and Oakland are are pretty
high up there next as well
all right so
we've queried you know the geographies
for one particular data set not all data
sets actually support all geographies
and so we can look at other data sets so
there's another commonly used data set
uh called uh Public Law 94 171. this is
unlike the ACs it's only published once
every 10 years and its primary purpose
is for redistricting congressional
districts right so it it has fewer
variables it has population and some
some diverse some ethnicity and race
variables but
um it has them over a very large number
of of areas right so if we compare over
the years the the geographies and all
I'm really doing here is counting for
the ACs how many different geography
paths were available each year usually
about 80 for you know for some reason in
2017 and 2018
they dropped two of them and then in
2019 or 2020 they either replaced them
or or brought them back but then you can
see like in the in the Public Law data
set it's only published once every 10
years and back in 2000 it had very few
geographies available well only 28 but
nowadays it actually has more than uh
than are available in the ACs in fact it
actually goes has some that go down to
the Block Level that I was talking about
before
right so so we've talked about how to
discover the geometries that are
available for a particular data set but
we haven't talked about how to discover
data sets and more importantly the
variables that they contain so that's
what we're going to do next which will
eventually get us back to you know the
the median household income variable
that we've been using all along
so how do we discover data sets well uh
there's a simple API for that we just
ask for all data sets and what we get
back like basically all our apis is a
data frame and this data frame you can
see it's got the over 1300 rows and it's
telling us about all these different
data sets that exist in different
vintages uh over the years right so you
know there's one for County Business
patterns so we can dig into that they're
probably you know all kinds of economic
variables in that one
um there's some you know
um
post-secondary employment outcomes right
so uh data about how people are are
employed post uh secondary education
right and there are a lot more in
between right so I could I could scroll
through all of these or because it's a
data frame I can just you know kind of
prep through it essentially I just say
well I'm looking for data sets whose
title contains you know American
Community survey five here right and
that's probably not the first query I
did the first one was probably ACS or
American Community survey and I got more
results than this and but two or three
attempts in I got down to this you know
nice little uh set of of data sets and
you can see each one has a year and then
you know ACS acs5 that's how I knew what
to pass to the data API right I got it
from this metadata API and
um there are some data sets that you
know not all a lot of people use as much
as the main ACS but to have additional
information
derived from from the ACs right so now
that I've found the data set I want I
have to find the the variables that I
want and because there are so many
variables in a lot of data sets they
tend to be organized into groups so I
can query for a given data set in a
given year what are all the groups of
variables that are available that's what
I did here for the acs-5 in 2020 and you
can see you know each one has a this
alphanumeric name and then it has a
description right so
um sentence by age is the first one but
then there's you know public health
insurance uh data uh is kind of the last
one is all kinds of other social
demographic uh and economic data in the
you know 1100 rows that are that are in
between here so you know 1100 different
groups I'm looking for
um for median household income which
I'll come back to in a minute but let's
just look at at one other data set right
the ACs has you know 1100 different
groups if we go back to that Public Law
data set it has it had more geometries
and very narrow geometries but it
actually only has six groups of
variables right it's it's done once
every 10 years for a very specific
purpose and it only has these small
number of
variables about population rate race and
ethnicity
okay so back to finding our median
household income
so we can search through the groups and
look for median household income in
their description you'll see you know
there's actually a bunch there's what 20
or so here uh different groups of
variables all that talk about median
household income in one way or another
right so this is one at the top that's
just you know median household didn't
come in the last 12 months in 2020
dollars
that's probably where we want to go
right that's the most basic and not tied
up with anything else data set you know
but there are other
um there are other data sets so for
example there's uh there's this one
median household income the past 12
months by tenure so tenure in the census
parlance means you know are people
homeowners or are they renters right so
we could look in that data set and find
out oh what are the differences in
median household between owners and
renters for example
but this one looks like the the the uh
one I probably want to use so I can take
the next step down the hierarchy and say
for that group what variables does it
contain right so the data set the
Vintage the group and it turns out this
one only contains one variable most
groups contain more than one variable
this one only contains one and it's our
old friend you know
b190013 or o13 underscore
001 heat right and we can read the the
label it's it's median household income
so that's how this what I did in the
last few cells that's how before I
started I actually found out what that
variable was that we used in our hello
world queries I was able to you know in
just a few queries drill down through
the data set the group and and the
variable to find whatever
so I mentioned you know uh most groups
have more than one variable here's
here's one that has three right so this
is that other one that median household
income by tenure and you can see it has
the first variable
median household income total so that's
everybody right and then it has a
variable for uh owner occupied
households so this is just the people
who own their homes what's their media
income and then it has another one for
renters right so
that total that should have the same
values as that other variable I just had
but the um the other two break it down
into into two subgroups
so these variable groups you can kind of
see it if you uh if you parse it out
with these bang bang and some other
special characters they use but there's
an implied tree here right and so we can
look at that tree in a more friendly
format uh just by asking you know group
tree so what are the variables in the
group organized as a tree right and you
see here again the the total variable
household income for everyone and it's
divided into two pieces that are leaves
of the tree the owner occupied in the
rental occupied
okay so some trees are much deeper than
that here's an example from the public
Law decennial Public Law data set that
we were talking about before so this
tree has at its very top a variable
which is total population everyone who
lives in that state or County or walk or
whatever
and then it has one leaf which is
Hispanic or Latinos so everyone who
identifies ethnically as Hispanic or
Latino is counted in that
variable which is also a leaf of the
tree but it has a sibling called not
Hispanic or Latino so that's everyone
else and for those people this
particular data set goes deeper on the
Hispanic or Latino side it stops but it
goes deeper elsewhere and uh and then
you know divides people up into people
who reported belonging to one racial
group and what they reported you know
were they white black
Asian whatever they they reported being
and then there's another sibling of that
for people who reported they were of two
or more races or uh and you know the
tree goes down and as you can see it
gets very very deep
um and has you know a great deal of of
detail in terms of exactly what it what
it covers
okay so sometimes we want just the
leaves particularly when we're dealing
with demographic data and looking at
things like diversity integration we
just want the leaves we don't want the
intermediate nodes where we're summing
stuff up in the middle or we're going to
end up having problems with double
accounting people so we could you know
kind of walk that tree and come up with
a list or we can just ask uh the API you
know what are the leaves right and then
it tells us remember in that first uh
you know first group we looked at there
were only two leaves for the renters the
owners in this bigger one you know there
are a lot more leaves and those various
internal modes as well
so if I want to query all the variables
in a group or maybe all the leaves
they're simple apis for that right in
fact we go back to the same API we were
using before
um and I just specified that I want the
name variable but then I say okay get me
also all the variables that are in this
group right so I didn't have to list
them out it will go and do that medical
data query figure out what they are and
and get the data for me and so it did
that and sure enough I've got the name
and then I've got the three variables
right so in California where my overall
median household income was
um you know 78 000 and change among
homeowners it's over a hundred thousand
right and we'd expect homeowners to
typically have a higher median income uh
among renters it's much lower and we see
that same pattern in the other states
that query
so sometimes we want just the leaves as
I mentioned so instead of saying group
equals I can just say leaves of group
equals and in this case with this small
tree it just left out the root it left
out the one for everybody and just has
the one column for homeowners and the
other column for for renters
if we look at the leaves of you know a
much larger tree so this is that that
tree on race and ethnicity that went
really deep and had tons of of leaves
um you know that group was called P2 and
I query that group for the three states
and you see I get my three rows but I
get a very very wide uh data set in this
case right so
um you know and what it tells me
California uh has uh 15 million people
who identify as being Hispanic or Latino
it has 13.7 million who don't but
identify as being white uh and so on and
so forth all the way across on the table
all right so we are halfway through our
90 minutes uh 45 minutes in I think just
about on the dot pretty pretty happy
with that so at this point I wanted to
give you a chance to take a five minute
break get up stretch your legs
um we'll reconvene in five minutes and
we'll put everything that we've just
been talking about together into one
case study where we'll look at you know
how can we identify areas where the
significant child would operate in in
Newark New Jersey so I'll see you all
back here at 20 after thank you
oh and there's also a bunch of resources
uh you may want to take a look at during
the break as well
foreign
Merry Christmas
[Music]
but
what I do yeah
thank you
yeah
but it should be next week
Republicans
cheers are playing for me but have a
great time
[Music]
all right
get started again
enjoyed the brief break from
90 minutes presentation
[Music]
so as promised I'm going to now show you
know sort of how we put this all
together going actually in the correct
order this time from you know we have a
research question too we actually have
an output that has an interesting answer
to that research question so the
particular uh scenario that we're going
to look at is we want to we have this
you know maybe we're working with the
city or a non-profit or other government
agency but for one reason or another we
want to know you know where in Newark
New Jersey are there concentrations of
children living in poverty
because we want to
develop some Services presumably that
are in our system getting out of poverty
so I'll skip over the basic Imports but
um first question we have to ask is you
know what data do we want what what are
the groups and the variables kind of the
thing I was doing towards the end of the
of the first half of this presentation
and so
um I'm going to start with the ACs data
set just because it's so Broad and so
wide it has so many things in it
um yeah I you know have a pretty good
hunch that it has things about uh about
poverty so I'm going to look at that and
I'm going to look in uh in this case
vintage 2021 and
I'm gonna ignore that warning
and then what I'm going to do is just
like I did before I'm going to say okay
let me get all the groups of variables
that are available in that vintage from
the ACs right and then I'm going to say
okay well let me look for the ones that
somewhere in the description you know
contain the word poverty and contain the
word age right because I'm I'm
interested specifically in children a
lot of data sets are grouped by age
groups so that's probably going to help
me find it right and well it turns out
you know like I keep saying there are a
lot of groups and a lot of variables
especially in the ACs but also even in a
lot of the others some of them are very
very specific right like poverty status
in the past 12 months of grandparents
living with their own grandchildren
under 18 years by responsibility for
their own grandchildren so you know
there's going to be different groups of
whether they are the primary caregiver
or not within that data set so like I
said you don't get this many data sets
or this many variables and groups
without having some very very narrow
ones right
um so then there's another one here you
know poverty status in the past 12
months by sex and age that that's kind
of promising right
um that's gonna have poverty status you
know at least Group by age and you know
although it's grouped by gender as well
so you know if we weren't studying
specifically you know girls living in
poverty that would probably be a great
data set
um if we have to we can use it right we
can add up we can sum sum them up
um but it turns out uh let me actually
find it here
um
yeah here's the one uh here's one that
is actually oh no that's the wrong one
here we go perfect all right B 17020
this highlighted row right poverty
status in the past 12 months by age so
this is going to tell us how many people
in a particular area
are in poverty uh by different age
groups right so let's go with that one
um so we'll we'll make a constant for
that group and then I say okay let me
look at the tree of variables that's
actually in that group so I can
understand how it's structured
and you know like most Creeds at the top
it's got total so that's just going to
be the total population uh in a given
area right and then on one branch of the
tree I'm going to have
um people whose income in the past 12
months was below the poverty level right
so this will be everyone of all ages and
on the other side of the tree I have
people above the poverty level so those
two nodes will add up to the sum that
was at the root and then going further
down I can see they're actually divided
up by age group right there's not
formally a variable for you know
children or under 18 but there are three
separate variables that I can very
easily add up right to get the total
that I want even though you know they
could have for example put a you know
another level of a tree for children and
adults and then further divided it and
that would have had the sum I wanted it
they didn't do that so I'm just going to
add up the three that I want right so I
just you know rather than try to do this
programmatically I just kind of visually
look at the tree and say okay these are
the three variables that I want right
these are people living below the
poverty line uh that are under 18 years
old
okay so now I come to the geography side
right I've got the variables I want I
need to know the geography so
um as we saw before most cities and
towns in are usually designated places
by the Census Bureau right so I'm going
to query uh this data I'm going to query
the data set at the Vintage and the uh
just the name variable for all places in
New Jersey right because I don't I don't
really care about all places in New
Jersey but this is how I'm going to find
Newark and then I'm just going to say
okay which one has a name that starts
with Newark sometimes it's more than one
um in depending on the state but here
now there's only there's Newark city in
in New Jersey and its place is 5100
right so I'll make another consonant for
that so basically this is just kind of
my general workflow from
um research question through the
notebook step by step to kind of figure
out you know what constants what
variables what geographies and so on I'm
going to need before I finally get down
to being able to do my my actual data
query
okay so then I'm going to download uh
the name and then those three variables
that I want that add up to the number I
want for the new work in the state of
New Jersey and I'll go ahead and get the
geometry too just to make sure I'm I'm
on the right track right so here it is
I've got the three variables this is how
many children live in Newark in that are
in poverty in each of those three age
groups so quite a few right almost you
know eight or nine thousand in each of
those so so uh quite a lot
and then I often like to do kind of a
quick visual reference right so I
downloaded the geography along with that
and so I'll plot that map with the
background uh overlay so I can just sort
of visually see you know like yeah I
didn't didn't make some weird mistake
and got some Tiny Town on the other end
of the state
by mistake right here's uh you know
Newark Airport the port of Newark iron
bound and you know all downtown over
here but you know it looks looks like
Newark right
um it's got this funny little uh piece
that sticks off it that that actually
dates from the 1920s when uh Newark
tried to Annex a bunch of local towns
and uh a lot of them resisted but but
the three or four here kind of uh
created this little little Isthmus of
that is part of Newark to this day
um anyway okay so what we actually want
though is narrower data right we want
tract level data because we want to go
down to uh to you know narrow regions
within Newark uh in order to look at
where those children living in poverty
actually live within the city
now the problem we're going to run into
of course is that places are off spine
geometries whereas these are on spine
geometries right so these don't
necessarily exist within places right
some there may be some census tracts
that are a little bit inside the place
but mostly outside or vice versa so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to get all
of the census tracts in the county Essex
County that I happen to know that that
Newark is in and you know I could have
queried all the counties and looked up
Essex and I would have found it's it's
0-1-3 kind of like I found King County
in Washington but I happen to know that
so I just put it in and then I visually
inspect by plotting a map you know where
are all these census tracts in the
county and then where is Newark right so
Newark is this blue uh outline and then
this is all of Essex County and just
like we saw before you know the urban
areas are more dense you know the more
rural areas out in this part of the
county are are less dense and there's
you know some suburbs in here you know
that's like I guess Bloomfield Montclair
places like that are still pretty dense
but now what we want to do is we want to
get just those census tracts that are
inside Newark right we don't we don't
care at least for the moment what's
going on out here and so
we want to filter and so what we can do
the
um
the Geo data frame that we've been using
that extension of the data frame that
has geometry has a variety of geometric
operations it supports so we can you
know intersect in Union and whatever
and
um the problem is if I do a spatial join
with
um so that I'm doing that right here I'm
taking all the tracks and Essex that
have the data I want in them and doing a
spatial join with Newark which I had
that one row in the data table I
downloaded and then I want to plot that
and just make sure I got the right
answer and it looks like this
right so what went wrong here and this
is a super super common problem when
you're dealing with with geographies
right so some of these census tracts
like this one you know the actual
boundary of them you know maybe whoever
was making that map uh plotted that
boundary like down the middle of the
street or down the left side of the
street and whoever was plotting the
boundary of Newark plotted it down the
right side of the street so there's a
tiny intersection there and that's why
this one showed up right whereas here
you know this is the Passaic River
Running along here and you know the
towns that are on the other side of the
river probably whoever Drew their
boundaries and Drew those census tracts
you know they they use the width of the
river and they don't intersect right so
how do I deal with this well you know of
course what I could do is say well let
me find the area of intersection of all
of these and find the ones where it's
you know big and not small and so on and
that works and in fact that's what we're
going to do that but it gets really
hairy because these are all in latitude
and longitude and depending on how you
project it onto a plane
um the areas are different and you
really shouldn't do that when they're
that long you shouldn't compute the area
in terms of lat long you should use some
kind of projection where you're in a
coordinate space where you're measuring
meters in X and Y and then compute the
area and then compute the intersection
of the area and and figure out you know
which ones really belong and
so that's what we do
um but we wrapped it all up in this API
right spatial join mostly contains and
so what this does does all that
projection I was just talking about
computes the areas and then by default
says okay you join with Newark if more
than 80 of your area is within that
now you can change that threshold with
an optional argument you can make it 90
or 95 or whatever
um whatever other number you want it to
be
but the default almost always works and
if we plot the results here's what we
get right we've got the census tracts
that look like you know by and large in
fact in this case none of them even poke
out uh enough that they look like
they're they're outside at all sometimes
they do depending on what state and what
what place is and then you have to kind
of decide what you do uh with it but we
got a really good result here right and
again we've got you know small census
tracts here in in the densely populated
parts of town this is like you know
Newark Airport and the port of Newark
right this vast area but you know
pretty much no one lives there and so so
that's why it's so large
but this visual inspection step I find
is really important just to you know
make sure when we know what we're
talking about before we try and do
anything with with the data okay so now
we can actually do our analysis right
and our analysis in this case is
actually really simple right we just
have to add up those three variables but
our data at this point is in an ordinary
pen this data frame we can use you know
arbitrary machine learning models from
you know sklearn XG boost or like
whatever we want uh as long as we put
the results back in the data frame along
with the geometry
um you know then we have something
something super interesting right so
here you know I'll just add add up the
three
um
and then you know right here just make a
new column and uh sum those three
variables right super simple
um normally there would be you know that
would be kind of the meaning part of the
notebook where we did our modeling
analysis but then I plot them and here's
what I get right so now I can see
exactly where uh children are living in
poverty in large numbers in Newark uh
including this you know part that sticks
out a little bit here and then
um you know I can look at the top ten so
I can say okay which which of the census
tracts have the most uh or I can then do
that visually you know plot those top 10
uh census tracts by the most children
living in poverty and see where they are
in Newark overlaid on a map where I can
see what's going on so you know we're
pretty close if not all the way there to
something that you know we could present
to that agency that we're working with
and you know to people who aren't data
scientists and aren't
um you know fluent in this sort of thing
but you know basically anyone can look
at this map and say okay I see what's
going on here
is going on
there you know super interesting cases
like like this little tip out here
that's actually in Newark it turns out
this this area around it uh here that's
that's like South Orange and Maplewood
which are much more affluent uh suburbs
and there's a very popular Park you can
kind of see it right there
um you know just across outside New York
and I actually talked to a local
historian at one point who told me that
you know as late as the 1990s kind of
right along the Main Street there 24 7
there would be a South Orange police
cruiser parked there to make sure that
no kids from Newark came and used that
Park
um you know in 19 as late as the 1990s
and you can see poverty persists among
children in that area to this day like
yes you
did the rate of
power yeah
right that's correct and that that
absolutely and so you know that's an
example you could do it as a percent of
the total number of kids or of the
overall population
um yes absolutely you know this is sort
of just the The Bare Bones showing you
the type of analysis that you can do but
again once you have that data downloaded
yeah the sky's the limit in terms of
having analyze
so
with that you know as I said we kind of
are are there and in you know literally
what uh 20 minutes we're able to go from
a uh you know a research question to
finding where this the data lives within
the census's you know vast collection of
of variables and groups uh get the
geographies filter that you know clean
it up plot it
um and and really be ready to go so
um with that I think I will uh jump to
let's see
you know more of a uh open-ended
discussion at this point in our
remaining time so first you know thanks
everyone for attending
um there's also some other like as I
mentioned there's another notebook uh
you can take a look at it's in the
GitHub repo that's kind of a plug and
play uh repository for doing projects
like this
um and uh you know take a look at that
um we've got uh how long what 20 minutes
20 minutes
um for questions there are a couple of
mics
um if you can speak into the mic that
would be great uh happy to to talk about
any of this I'm also around for uh the
next couple days as well so feel free to
grab me at you know lunch or one of the
breaks I'll be around and happy to chat
yes
uh thank you
um is there any support for distance
from certain points
as as a you know example like how many
people within a radius of like 10 miles
Live From a Certain area of course yeah
an airport or uh
right so so great question so you can do
that
um I mean you can't do that directly in
the API because the underlying data
model looks different than that but what
you can do is uh and what I've done in
the past for queries like that is you go
down to the lowest level of granularity
that your data set has like for for a
query like that you know if I could get
a data set that went down to the Block
Level I'd do it otherwise I'd go to the
block group and then I'd say Okay
um you know from this given point I'd
probably depending on how big the radius
is but I'd probably say you know get the
counties for the state
um see how many of them using the the
spatial join functionality of the
geodata frames I'd say how many of these
Counties have at least part of them
within that radius of that point then I
as I did here I'd say well which of the
um you know which of the blocks are part
of those I wouldn't really care about
the ones that missed a little on the
outside and then I just join those with
a bond based on distance to get the
circle and add them up and I'd get a
little noise around the edges but that's
that's how uh how we typically approach
that kind of question
yes
um I saw on the when you were getting
the data from the poverty by age it's an
estimate yeah can you explain what that
means sure yeah so the American
Community survey that we got that data
from is as its name implies a survey so
unlike the decennial census that happens
every 10 years where their goal is to
talk to or get a form filled out by
literally every single person in the
country the cert the community survey is
a survey and so that almost all the
variables are qualified with that
estimate because it is you know this is
our best estimate of the number we
didn't talk to everybody there are other
variables you can get as part of those
data sets that tell you things about
margin of error and and you can look at
like the margin of error and different
geography levels and so on
um so you know to the extent that that
really matters to you
um you can you can sort of do these very
bounded kind of uh analysis where you
study the error bars and even how they
propagate through your analysis but
that's that's why they call it estimate
because they are but they also provide
additional data on you know what they
believe the accuracy of those estimates
to be based on the sample sizes
sorry
so just a follow-up who does that
estimate certainly Define what poverty
is what is the value yes
in the Census Data assembly it says Hey
for this year the poverty line is set
this
it's uh it is it's published by a
different agency but the census yes uh
their numbers refer to uh to that
um to That official Federal line
I haven't actually looked that up last
week poverty is defined as three times
the basket of food you need to buy for
the week so if you were earning less
than three times in which you pay for
food and you're recovery as Def and the
I think this Department of Commerce
decides how much food
so when people are doing an actual
poverty estimates that we should go with
twice that they do twice the fat but I'm
in heaven where I come from a Baltimore
County for a family of four it's like 50
000.
um Good Luck feeding a family of four
even ahead for fifty thousand a year
it's it's quite tough
um the question I had with the reason I
took my hand up and
you've shown this way of like a wrapping
through all the different tables that
you have is there like a Google for
census rules like can I just type in
African-American income 20 time right
and if it's so mean which table and
which field in that table I need to look
at because that's always the thing
that's closing them when I'm using the
census yeah the
so there are you know that these data
sets and tables and groups that I all
went down through there are
um web pages that are essentially tables
rendered from this I'm sure you've
probably seen them
um or maybe no oh well I've searched in
vain they they do exist in some obscure
corner of the census Department's
website uh the best I've the best way
I've found to do it with that is five
somehow find that page and then
literally just control left and like
search through it I I mean that that
that's why we do it this way and
um from your experience do you are there
any pitfalls or like common things
you've run across say like the
difference between cities and townships
that might throw people off or
because states can Define things
differently uh are there problems
comparing Apples to Apples sometimes
yeah that's a great question
um there are a few
um the state of Massachusetts is a
particularly strange one for whatever
reason in that
um
they the the way they have and probably
because you know they did this whatever
100 however many hundreds of years ago
they did it probably before the United
States even existed but they've divided
up the whole state into I forget what
they called them but but the Census
Bureau calls them County subdivisions
but in in and around Boston they really
pretty much are the towns and in the
other part of the state they're not
really and so that's one that
Massachusetts definitely trips people up
in that way and if you're not from
Massachusetts or don't regularly use
Massachusetts data we found this out the
hard way working with with housing
Navigator of Massachusetts
none of this but
um
yeah that's that's the one really
strange one that I
and where you have to be very careful
um I was just going to say another
um something that I have found is that
sometimes families will change names I
think there's Lakota County in
South Dakota and so the fitness code
changes for that County as well so if
you're not if you didn't notice that you
may have a blank spot in your map if
you're finding the dips schedule looking
for
yes that's absolutely right and and
there are there are other versions of
that same problem so as soon as you're
ever trying to do a study that goes
across from year to year to year
um you sometimes run into problems like
that even in the like definition of what
a sensitive government is right because
as I mentioned typically between one and
five thousand people well over time
people move around a lot and some of
these census tracts you know their
population explodes so what is the
Census Bureau do they cut that census
tract into two or three and Each of
which has a number that didn't exist
before and the number that existed
before no longer exists same same thing
as the counties who are talking about
and so you have to if you want to do a
study involving you know
what happened over the course of the
last 10 years you absolutely have to
from year to year do that same kind of
uh geometric analysis where I found what
was part of Newark to even like well
wait a minute this census tract
disappeared but what was it replaced
with
and then and then you have to remember
well okay then I'm gonna have to sum
those three up because they represent
what last year was one since
uh just anyone know one more thing that
you need to answer your question that
might you find weird in
in Census Data uh Virginia has some I
think they call them independent cities
uh or towns where in normal sense
ostensibly it would be what would be
like the Cali seat of uh accounting but
if you look at the shape file uh on the
map it's a completely simmered entity
from the rest of the county and
sometimes they even have the same names
um it's just one of those weird things I
ran into one time uh yeah it was in
Virginia yeah so some of the cities are
just they have the same name as the
county that completely you know
geometric geometrically surrounds them
but
a question about cadastral uh
information do you have any land
ownership Data Center
the wall again uh land ownership no
um just because that tends to be you
know like the Deeds are typically at the
county level and it's
the I have done some work where I needed
to do that and I in one case was super
lucky that the county had an API and in
a couple other cases it's basically you
scrape their website that's the only way
to do it that I've found
yes
in the same way when you can use yes or
something sometimes then this tool is
more helpful sure so you're talking
about GIS systems like esri and stuff
like that right so yeah I mean there's a
whole industry that's built all those
tools and they're very much built for
you know importing all kinds of data you
know not just sensitive data but lots of
other things and you know doing a lot of
the geometric and spatial stuff
typically in an interactive GUI kind of
application right and they're from you
know people that that spend their entire
day in front of these and
I think the the sort of when would you
want to go that route and when would you
want to go this route
I think the advantage here is kind of
the piece that I didn't really show or I
kind of glossed over right at the very
end is the analysis piece right you get
a whole with in this world you get a
whole bunch of data from the Census and
now you want to use SK learn you want to
use
you know XG boost you want to model it
it's statsma whatever the entire
ecosystem of
um you know of python machine learning
statistical analysis that kind of thing
this data once you've gotten it this way
is ready to go into that world
I mean I guess the other the other
difference is you know those high-end
GIS systems they can do some incredible
things they are not inexpensive
yes that corner
hi does all data sets capacity for the
data sets from other organizations like
the USDA that also have data science
products since extract like a food Atlas
research practice
sure so the census through their API
does I don't know about that specific
data set but there are definitely from
the Department of Commerce in particular
there are data sets that are derived
from Census Data the analysis is done by
the Commerce department and then they're
published back through this same API
thank you
this question is slightly off topic so
apologies when you were showing
Washington state right you have a whole
bunch of really really tiny census
tracks in the cities and a whole bunch
of really really big census tracks in
rural areas and so anything you plot at
that State level
whatever is going on in the rural areas
is going to dominate the images right
you have much more experience in this
than probably most of the people here
how do you how do you deal with that how
do you stop the story the rural areas
dominating the story of the world the
urban areas when you're making the
results
fantastic question
um
so in the same way that you know that I
projected the United States so it like
looked nice like if you're looking down
from space and one
except somehow Alaska was down here
um
there are projections that are you know
where the area is based not on area of
land but on some other variable and
they're typically done with the sort of
Monte Carlo or simulated annealing type
of approach where what you do is you say
oh you know what is you start with the
map as it exists and then you say oh
this area you know relative the area
that I plotted relative to the
population is either way too big or way
too small and so if it's way too big let
me shrink it a little bit and it'll sort
of pull its neighbors in with it and and
also some I'll expand right and and you
do that iteratively until you get
something relatively stable and
depending like sometimes it looks
totally crazy and you can't tell what's
going on but other times like I've seen
it done at the state level and you get a
map of the United States that's very
recognizable it's a map of the United
States but like the middle is squished
down to nothing and the coasts are
really big right
so I mean this this tool doesn't do any
of that but that's how I've seen it
all right anything else
or should I let you uh go enjoy uh the
break before the next session
yes thank you very much Dave